hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep I'm your host grace Helbig
we have Hank green back with us for
another episode last time he was here as
a few years ago and Lots has happened
since Lots has happened since we talked
about his newest novel a beautifully
foolish endeavor and the original title
and why the original title might have
been a little bleak and not so hopeful
as the current title is we also talked
about what it's like being the poster
child for a tick-tock we learned about
the algorithm ins and outs of it we also
learned a lot about science and a lot
about a man of wars more than I thought
I would ever in my life let alone on one
episode of a podcast of not too deep but
we do get ready for another episode of
naughty deep with Hank green
Hank green thank you for being here
tic TOCs coverboy Hank green
Oh have you seen my Tech Talks oh I just
went on a journey of the Hank green tic
tacs and look I am I'm a big fan of you
know delete this and dear Hank and John
I listen to them very regularly so I've
only heard you mention this tick tock
journey that you've been on yes in in
both podcasts and so I you know knowing
that you were gonna be here with us
today did my research and Wow what do
you think I mean I get it it's your your
tick tocks I've been so confused and
have felt like I can't puncture the the
hole or the bubble that is tick-tock and
I kind of you help me kind of get it
yeah it's got a really specific energy
that is actually very similar to mine
overall what are your personal energy
yeah like it's for its frenetic it's
never focused on any one thing for more
than 15 seconds yeah and like one of the
other things that I like very much about
tick tock is that like failure is both
fine and expected yes I was worried
about making content because people be
like why did you make that thing did you
think that was gonna be successful you
don't understand the platform but it's
just like actual most like tick stalkers
make like eight videos a day I know back
to all of them to do poorly that's the
one thing because I also couldn't do
vine like I don't know if chemically I
just wasn't made for it and I was right
yeah and so that's my kind of blind
association with tick tock is that it's
got that kind of energy but it really
does like put a saddle on anxiety and
like lets you ride it yeah it is
because even just looking at your
homepage all of the thumbnails are just
like gyrating a little bit which creates
when you look at it in whole a very
anxiety inducing experience versus like
looking at someone on Instagram that has
a parody aesthetically curated yeah like
monochromatic or whatever kind of thing
yeah and so I get it that it just like
allows you to use that kind of unbridled
unhinged frenetic energy yeah and
absolutely no idea what's gonna do well
no idea I'll I'll like I'll be like this
one's gold this one's going this one's
huge and it'll get like 20,000 views and
then I'll just like do this offhanded
crap that's got like a half joke in it
and it gives like 10 million is there
any familiarity to the beginning of
YouTube absolutely yeah you know there's
a couple of really familiar things one
is that nobody's doing it for money
because there isn't much you have to
have a very big tick-tock audience to be
making any money at all on the platform
right and so it and the other reason
that it's not about money is that like
at the moment that you start to want to
turn your creative tick-tock endeavor
into something you know you have to be
spending time doing that rather than
spending time making your tick tocks
and and if you are spending time doing
that or like seem interested in drawing
people off of that platform there's
always somebody else ready to take your
spot like you have very little control
over your audience which is very
different from early YouTube where like
early YouTube we you know subscribers
was the main way that you got views and
you had that really tight relationship
with them bras I'm tick-tock it feels
very much like I don't have a couple of
people but mostly I don't have a very
tight relationship with any of the
people I follow on tik-tok and don't
really even expect to see them on my
free You page that often right the so is
that as someone that's you know live the
whole whatever blueprint of YouTube now
is that more exciting to you to be on
tick-tock where you have no ability to
analyze and kind of figure out how this
algorithm works or is it more
frustrating to be like I can't figure
out how this goddamn algorithm works
well yeah yeah I mean I I think I
understand perfectly how the algorithm
works which is that it is designed to
give you random reward which is how you
hack a human brain to continue trying
something and if youth if you if you
give people a clear path
- how to get to the reward then that is
much less appealing than when if they
don't quite know and then they try all
kinds of things and behave in all kinds
of irrational ways and continue seeking
the reward this works on dogs this works
on people this works on children like
it's really like casino level stuff yeah
there's a oh man that just brought me
back to I remember taking an improv
class it when I was like early early 20s
and we had an exercise that we did that
was like the hardest one of our class
where a teacher told us we had we had to
do improv by herself in front of the
whole class and we couldn't stop until
her teacher told us we were allowed to
stop
so it like pushed you to keep trying
different things to get your teacher to
tell you okay you've completed your
exercise and it was the most vulnerable
Rolfing and frustrating people were
crying at moments which is what I
assumed tick-tock is just putting it out
there yeah I mean it is very open and
creative and wild and weird and um it
reminds me of really YouTube in a lot of
ways and it's also like very clearly the
way that people are getting noticed now
like it's so hard to break through on
YouTube and it's and so hard and even
you know Facebook Twitter Instagram all
those places have got twitch too has
gotten harder to break through but on on
tik-tok there's both like the because
you can't make money a lot of bigger
creators kind of our art and also it's
kind of got a fairly impenetrable
culture sometimes a lot of bigger
creators aren't aren't taking the time
to to interface with it and honestly I
wouldn't either if I wasn't like just
sort of deeply curious about internet
media the only reason I started doing it
was because I was like okay fine I need
to understand this platform and I'm not
gonna understand it unless I make
content on it you sure but you're also a
human being that martyr's yourself for
your craft I like to delete this I know
what Kathryn feels about how involved
you are and everything that you're doing
so pile it on with added tick-tock you
know I really do have to stop making
tick-tock spare
soon just because I've got a lot else
going on and there's no there's also a
piece of me that wanted to sort of build
up a little tick-tock following for my
book watch well no that's not like you
shouldn't feel weird about that that's
that's just natural good strategy
marketing etc yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of a lot of it feels like
a lot of my people are on tick-tock like
a lot of old nerdfighters or you know
people who watch crash course and
scishow are on that platform so that's
great yeah okay well let's talk about a
beautifully foolish endeavor oh yeah
yeah okay good okay um cuz I will not
stop talking about tick-tock if you
don't stop me no I know and this is how
I'm just using you as like my source of
information for all things tick-tock
because I'm honestly watching you tick
tock makes me believe that I could take
- are you totally [ __ ] good you are
you would I think you would kill its you
have to like let it all go and be like
okay this is a tick tock I guess that's
what looks so wonderful about it is that
it does feel like only wild mistakes are
embraced on there and that's like my
whole core self yeah okay a beauty of
the beautifully foolish endeavor wasn't
the original title I know what was the
original title I can't tell you I don't
it might be a little bit of us did I
tell somebody I think I know you might
have just misspoke in the title in a pot
oh yeah oh yeah okay I'll tell you that
version sure but there well grace there
were a number of different titles and
for a long time I'm prepping you for
your whole press round that you'll have
to do for the book now yeah that for a
while the title was a beautifully futile
endeavor which I like a lot like I like
for a lot of reasons um I think that it
it sounds better in the mouth it's got a
better than feel uh beautifully feel
well uh nice crude but the feedback was
we don't love that feel the vibe is a
little off I don't know if anybody's
gonna want to read a book that's just
about it
beautifully futile endeavor which is you
know a kind of a little bit how I feel
about humanity which is also you know
that's that's what the title refers to
it's talking about you know people and
our our endeavor but ultimately is it is
futile and and a little bit of the
beauty in it isn't its futility like
there will come a day and I predict it
will be long from now when there will be
no humans left to remember that humans
were ever here and so like this thing
that we sort of imagined as the human
story is you know that that like at like
legacy and you know like being
remembered in anyway all of that to me
is like ultimately you know maybe it's
maybe it's kind of got a beauty to it
but it's very futile what's not futile
is like making things so that people
today and tomorrow and all the days
after that we'll have a slightly better
life and like that's you know it but
that's about them in that time not about
humanity as a whole that sort of is a
thing that stretches infinitely into the
future and I like that's sort of like my
touchstone when I'm trying to imagine
like the human endeavor and sort of a
large-scale way is that it's it's much
more about affecting the people that we
that we you know love now and that we
want to like alleviate the suffering of
now but also you know how how that will
you know move on to you know
theoretically most of the people who are
people who haven't been born yet like
that's the hope is that most of the
people haven't been born yet and those
are the people that were you know we
ultimately also have an obligation to so
teens can read this philosophy does not
really exist in the book it just didn't
forms the book I mean it sounds like
you've gone to a very I mean I it it's
really wonderful and so cool and so like
empowering to be able to use a novel as
a vehicle
to really write the deep or darker
thoughts that you have about and
predictions that you have about humanity
in general so you must have kind of had
to dip into some bleaker more futile
places in your brain to think about it
and then kind of like reform it into
something that doesn't totally terrified
humans yeah well and it is a little bit
terrifying I think that you know anytime
we're you know dealing with like death
is very scary and then like but we sort
of alleviate that fear by thinking about
you know that the species continues or
that the human story continues and then
but then there's also that thing that
like eventually there's gonna be some
sort of species wide and uh probably
probably I don't know maybe not maybe
we'll figure something out but like from
what I know of how physics works it
would be hard hard to go on for you know
tens of billions of years would be
difficult but like that's very much be
it like it's that's practically infinite
by our current timescales so but but
yeah I mean the book is you know to some
extent it's about it so there is a
character in the book who has a fairly
good idea of what the future of humans
might look like
no it's car okay and and so and and
because of that I have to sort of from
my perspective like silently on the
outside of the author also kind of feel
like I have that which of course I don't
like the character actually does in the
universe of the novel whereas I don't
really and interestingly like Carl and I
come down on different spots on this
like Carl believes a different thing
than I actually do but like it was an
interesting story with Carl Carl having
a different opinion than me that and
that must be difficult and also very
cathartic to write through characters
that have different opinions than you
like when you're writing you know you're
writing these characters that are super
rich super complex are you
doing anything exercise wise to like
break them down into like their moral
codes in certain ways like their their
Hogwarts houses if you will their
myers-briggs personalities all of that
yeah there's a there's several like a
lot of it is their backstory so things
that you know like and that's how I sort
of touchstone to it instead of thinking
about myers-briggs or something I my
sort of like building block is a few
stories that I know about their past
that informs who they are that like the
reader never knows and that just sort of
helps me like sort of formative
experiences that they had that I can
look to when they're in a difficult like
they're having to make a difficult
decision or you know they're trying to
solve a hard problem now that makes so
much sense and obviously makes it so
much clearer for you when you do hit an
impasse of how to navigate in that
characters point of view knowing all of
that backstory because that's what
humans do so as of now while we're
recording this episode your book has yet
to be read by people other than close
confidants your brother who a couple
aids we have there we just got a couple
of reviews from people who are not who
like our page do have opinions about
books and not paid to make me feel good
about myself
which is very good because both of the
reviews were very good great and it just
makes me feel very happy because like
that's that's the first time you really
know right so it that's my question in
that time like you it's like you know
cooking a meal so you're like I've added
everything I think makes this meal great
yeah are they gonna think it's great I
don't know like what is that limbo
period like it's terrible you know the
the solution is generally like opened
the book for you to page of the book and
it's think to yourself
that was good um sometimes though you
open the book read a page of the book
and you're like there's a couple things
that would have changed there that's
actually not sure if I'd really did that
one perfect
and so like that that's actually during
the process of writing the book there's
a lot it's very it would be very unusual
I think for authors to sort of not have
a little bit of negative self-talk and
like think that of course like why am i
why am I doing this this is bad and that
this is sounds a little egotistical but
the way that the path over that for me
is always like reading some of the book
and being like well that was good like I
liked that guy was like that was good
that made me feel interested in the
story and I think that I did a good job
of telling that joke and etc so great
but but like you but yes the the period
of time between when the book is locked
and when you get the first review is
basically for me it's a constant
practice of trying to not think about it
because thinking about it is is always
bad yeah like the moment I think about
it it's just like straight anxiety
spiral sweaty pits and like completely
distracted from everything else in my
life by that thought sure yeah but and
then and and yeah and and then the first
review comes out and like literally
jumped up and down I was so excited
because I've been spending so much time
like trying not to think about this at
the moment that review had my inbox and
it was a starter view from library
journal just like a basically a
publication for librarians yeah just
heard about this on dear Hank and John
oh you guys explained exactly what a
one-star review is a very very number
that's the number of stars you can get
and a review is one star which is they
should talk to Yelp and clarify a star
system yeah don't get a star basically
congratulations yeah and I was yeah yeah
I had like that was the relief was
massive and and they got it to like the
things that they liked about the book
are also things that I liked about the
book a lot that's great because when
you're do you ever have a certain person
in mind that you are writing
specifically for for the like one person
to enjoy this book know your kind of
writing rod I don't think about I don't
think about that I don't even
don't think about other people got it
[Music]
that's interesting yeah I I'm just
trying to tell the story I guess no
that's I mean that's great everyone has
their system and I'm always fascinated
as to like what
maybe you've adopted or don't even know
that you've adopted because yes is your
second novel compared to the first
Bezier oh a harder significantly harder
a couple really yeah I mean I didn't
have a time limit on the first one so I
I just like I wrote it for like eight
years and I like threw stuff away and
rewrote stuff constantly
and like ignored it for months at a time
whereas this one I had a deadline and
but that was very different and I also
like just stylistically I changed some
things up it's a little bit longer so
that takes more time and and also it's
from multiple points of view so the
first book was almost all except for the
last chapter from one person's point of
view just just April sort of like
writing her memoir and this one April's
not around mm-hmm
she's not trying to avoid spoilers here
she's been around and the or is she or
is she she actually does have the first
chapter so like you'll see you'll see
her so uh and that's known that's not
that's that's not new information so and
then the rest of them are from the
perspective of four other characters and
so I had to like write all these other
characters and that was really difficult
because I had like getting into April's
head you know it was hard but like once
I was there I was there switching back
and forth all the time and there was a
lot of times and I wrote a scene from
one person's point of view and then it
like didn't fit into this story right so
I'd have to rewrite the scene from
another person's point of view it was
really an interesting exercise because
like they're like as I did it I was like
your brain is different you imagine
things differently than that other
character you see this all differently
you're you know you're not seeing
yourself and so you're like and so I
you don't like to you know we don't even
always we usually don't know what we
look like or what our faces are doing
and so you know that is all that's like
that that's a really fun exercise to do
in in general I think but like it turned
out it was a thing I had to do
accidentally no that's uh yeah I think
in basic terms what it's like empathy or
compassion are offshoots of that
exercise just being able to understand
someone else's point of view and exactly
how they would respond to a situation
and why is a super fascinating yeah okay
we're going to take a quick break when
we get back I have more questions for
you and then I also have some questions
from the internet for you so before I
look more not too deep hey guys we're
taking a break from the podcast real
quick to do some promotion of ourselves
that's right yes we are promoting
ourselves a little reminder to you guys
out there but if you go into the Apple
podcasts and you rate and review not too
deep it's a beautiful wonderful helpful
thing for us and for you guys it helps
people find our podcast that helps us
hear what you guys like what you don't
like etc and we just appreciate you
taking the time again go to Apple
podcast leave us a rating review
whatever you want okay we're back in
speaking of quarantine have you and
Katherine learned anything new about
each other in this quarantine because my
favorite thing of listening to delete
this which if you guys don't know Hank
and Katherine have a wonderful podcast
called delete this and it just makes you
while you're listening to it feel like
you're crawled up in bed with them like
crunching on chips and just like looking
at a computer screen I love that the
microphone sounds like it's ten years
away from you well produced yes and then
you guys will just spend like 20 minutes
watching a cat video
just laughing at it explaining
explaining nothing to people that are
only listening we try to explain no I
love it I love how casual it is and I
love how Catherine's just so over it
immediately
wonderful
but in quarantine you guys have
obviously probably been spending way
more time together have you learned
anything new I think that we definitely
learned
I mean Catherine and I have both learned
that like my seemingly infinite capacity
for like getting [ __ ] done is not
infinite and and so we have had to look
harder at our of my priorities not our
priorities Catherine's are pretty in
order every episode is Catherine just
publicly stating how much she doesn't
condone you working as hard on as many
things as a theme it's literally like
her last course of action is to say it
on the podcasts to get somebody to back
her up does anybody agree with me on
this yeah don't worry they do they all
do and yeah and so but but actually I've
had I had to do it yeah like like
physically you know I just like it
didn't have enough time to do all the
obligations that I that were that I had
signed up for and you know my life got
like more complicated it didn't have
like extra time when Quarantine rolled
around I had much less because trying to
like figure out how to run a business in
in this time and like how to keep
everybody safe and employed and like
changed the way that we operate out of
our warehouse and like all this stuff
which you know was really important but
you know it's all stuff no one sees it's
all happening behind the scenes
sure yeah yeah yeah and and all like
really important stuff but like yeah so
I went down to not too much less sleep
than I usually get and that clearly
started to look unsustainable and yeah
and
so I kind of like I met my limit you
know I finally figured out where it was
now I know that's great and it only took
a global pandemic you to get there but I
feel like that's a little bit of what's
happening with everyone that's been in
the digital space for a certain period
of time everyone's having a little bit
of that reflective moment of where do we
go from here how do we go from here
where we what do we go from here
situation I think there's also like a
certain amount of like locating strength
in a in a hard time where you know I
think we could be surprised by the
strength of our family members when
especially it's sort of like you know in
a more traditional role like I might
feel like I'm the one who must like
provide the strength and support in the
difficult time because I am the man and
and like finding that there were gonna
be times and I was going to be weak and
feel really sort of broken in and
helpless and feel like a failure like at
times and and to have you know and also
Katherine would have these times when
she'd feel really uncertain and not know
what to do and like knowing that we
could be strong for each other in the
moments when we needed it was trusting
each other truly interesting like your
abilities to support each other
mm-hm at any particular moment because I
feel like this time so wild that it's
impossible to predict like when that
overwhelm is going to wash over you and
you feel like the weight of the world
and then the moments when you feel like
now it's time to tick-tock let's do I
wish I could get gathered to tick-tock
with me I just a slightly over at
Katherine in the background of your
t-box
is like it's like coming to the room and
I'm like doing it is like
I love it so much that I that I do I do
think that I will never do a tick-tock
dance I could probably pull it off but
it looks like it these kids are good
dancers looks like a lot of work it's so
impressive that it's a it and it blows
my mind that that's what I am finding
impressive at this you know state the
world and my age yeah it is it's wildly
impressive but I just know that I can't
do it so I have to appreciate the people
you can what's it like having the
coolest son it's so good he's great as
Oren is he's he's like three-and-a-half
right now he's reached that point where
he kind of is starting to understand
things oh yeah yeah yeah he gets some
stuff pretty well um you know he knows
when he knows when like a good thing is
gonna happen and you know the bad things
gonna happen
yeah well the good yeah you have to like
adjust your adjust your perspective on
what a good thing is things like
watching Octonauts
yeah just knows how to appreciate the
small things and exactly and and it's
it's a it is such an interesting thing
to watch a person become themselves a
little bit to watch their personality
form and to you know see their like
orange like weird interests I don't like
I don't like I don't know where why he
gets in into like certain things and I'm
like is that just was that me that I
like to like express value in that
object or was that you were you just
like some like a kid who's really into
the moon and he's super into the moon
always has been every time the moon's up
in the sky he sees it
wave off like he like every time he
walks outside he like looks checks to
make sure the moon's up like or not he
knows something that we don't know it's
still parked in the
period one of the one of the first like
more complex sentences he ever said was
moon friend always comes back
wow that is incredibly ominous as
something visited your window in the
night what's yeah
what are his interest cuz that to me is
so fascinating where he's at the phase
where he's like I mean children are
sponges like like I said like is this me
or did you naturally find this
interesting right yeah he loves I mean
he loves to read you loves to read by
which I mean she loves to have me read
to him and and he loves to throw things
this is one of his major interests was
throwing things particularly if he can
throw them into either a hole or a body
of water which I don't think is
perfectly equivalent to him but he loves
it when he throws something and then he
can't have it anymore
he's like basically I've made this thing
vanish there's on our street there's
like somebody's sawed off a chain-link
fence
that's like sunk into asphalt they
couldn't get out of the asphalt they
just sawed it off so like the base of
the of the the chain-link fence is still
open and so it's like a little round
hole that's just dark insides just
darkness in there and Oren over the last
year has filled up every one of them
stuff will stay and stuff he picks up
fits in the hole and I'm like we're
going we're going on a walk and he's
like I just got to put a couple more
rocks into this hole completion yeah
have you spent any time thinking about
what you do in relation to showing him
eventually Oh what do you like like
videos like Oh like right the the
eventual understanding that you do
things that effect
many people oh yeah alright other people
don't have the same job as me I haven't
sleigh I haven't spent much time
thinking about that
he likes my songs like he will request
you'll come into my office and be like
Daddy play anglerfish by Hank green you
don't feel like but the artists on it
it's just I know what you mean
and so yeah he knows that I can play
songs but I don't think he thinks that's
weird or exceptional and and he also
watches scishow kids our kids show and I
am occasionally on that show so when I
show up he's like there's daddy daddy's
there but I don't think he thinks that's
weird either my good thing ray it just
thinks that like daddy's in the video
sometimes and he like he's watched me
edit video like sometimes he like sits
on my lap while I make vlog brothers and
so he's sort of I don't know if he has
any idea what I'm doing I think he
thinks I'm just like watching bad weird
video yeah well speaking of the this
side the whole science side of it is not
only have you written your second book
but you still are heavily involved in
science and we're in this pandemic and
I'm sure you've looked at everything and
my biggest question cuz I did see this
on your tick-tock a little bit is the
idea of debunking scientific information
that is false that goes viral because I
think that is kind of one of the more
major things happening right now and
especially for myself where I'm going
online and trying to figure out and stay
informed and you know if something is
just passed around kind of frivolously
you have to really check yourself on
making sure you don't take you know
frivolous as fact do you feel a major
obligation to be kind of like regulating
this right now or just like calling out
for people to acknowledge that this is
possible and to do their own like due
diligence research kind of thing yeah I
mean I recognize that like right now is
very is hard
than it's ever been because usually when
we're doing science communication we're
communicating about stuff that we that
we've had a lot of time to learn that
we've done a lot of checking on that we
you know have we've had the time to do
the research and research takes time and
during this period we have had to sort
of that go with what felt what was best
at the moment and the best information
that we had at the time is gonna be
different from the best information that
we have now and that's a hard thing to
explain to people because in general we
we that the science story is generally
pitched as like here's that here's all
the things and then if you get more
nuanced than that it's like here's all
the things we know but but like the like
it's very important and also if you are
in science communication or in science
but you know is that like we are in the
middle of science we have gotten this
far through and there is like basically
infinite things that we don't know and
we don't talk about the things that we
don't know because we don't know them
like that because we don't want to admit
it but because like it's not interesting
because we don't know them right you
know and it's it can be interesting to
say like you know we don't really know
how Portuguese man-of-war breed like
that's that's an interesting thing that
we don't know but like we don't but it's
it's much it's much less interesting
than Portuguese Man O'War are actually
not an organism there are four different
organisms that rely on each other to
survive and integrate their flesh
together but have distinct nervous
systems and genetic material and that's
like so like this animal is not an
animal it's four different animals and
like sorry that's how it works yeah so
like that's that's more interesting and
that's a thing that we know but like if
we knew how Portuguese Man O'War bred
there'd probably be something similarly
weird that we could that I could tell
you but like I just don't have a great
idea of how it works we know a couple
things but so like like there's you know
we we and that we also mostly when we
teach people we don't teach them
that like there's all this stuff we
don't know or even that the stuff that
we found out was once stuff that we
didn't know in many cases up until very
recently and and and so that that
presents this idea that science is this
static thing and it's a body of
knowledge and then when science sort of
like like says a different thing one day
then another day then it feels like oh
all credibility has been lost unless you
sort of understand that this is a
process not a static body of knowledge
no go ahead that's yeah that no that's
very interesting the way that you put
that because that makes sense by people
with short tempers immediately lose
their patience yeah scientists and
doctors and and the like because it is
an ever-evolving yeah academic world and
there's it's impossible to know
absolutely everything about everything
right and and like you know with
something that's like very new like like
the control of it the spread of a
specific disease we're not gonna know
anything at first and and so you know
you give the best information that you
know like with mask-wearing for example
like you don't want to like run out of
masks for health care professionals so
initially you say well we're not sure if
masks are gonna help and so don't worry
about it right now then research comes
out that says that masks definitely do
help and also we have way more of them
because we were able to scale up
production capacity so definitely wear a
mask and suddenly it's like well you
told me a different thing a month ago I
can't trust you and it's like well like
there's a reason why we told you a
different thing a month ago and like
reasons have changed as for like how
obligated I feel to communicate and to
fight against misinformation very
especially like right now when it comes
to masks it is very important that when
we are indoors with other people that we
are met wearing masks like that is a
thing that's going to save lives
it's a gonna be a thing that will allow
the economy to reopen and stay opened
for a longer it's gonna have people like
it's gonna allow us to continue to have
jobs and help each other and you know
it's going to keep people who have
worked there
whole lives to make this country better
and are now and there's 60s and 70s and
80s it's gonna keep those people alive
and we're gonna protect those people who
are people that we should can care about
and and like that like you are not
wearing a mask to protect yourself
you're wearing a mask to protect as the
other people and you're wearing a mask
to normalize it so that other people see
that and say like oh it's it's normal to
wear a mask and I shouldn't feel weird
about this
it's like shoes it's like shoes it's
just like shoes we don't have to loose
shoes but we wear shoes and if we just
make a mask style video like shoes the
YouTube video I think that they I think
that could work I also wonder when you
were talking about how you know the way
in which you speak about science is
ever-evolving so people get upset when
suddenly something is slightly different
than what was reported before I wonder
if there's a way to present science like
a reality television show
like previously on science yeah and then
you say what the story was before and
your knowledge and then it's under the
you know narrative in this structure
that it's going to be changing and
evolving as the storyline progresses I
wonder where people could get on board
with like that well I mean and that's
that's uh that's basically the story of
every every science news story is that
like previously we thought X but
actually Y and so we just want to jazz
up the editing and get a couple
scientists that really have low morals
to be involved and to create some sort
of drama mm-hmm there is reality TV that
doesn't rely exclusively on drama
you just gotta it's like we have to have
like what are you watching I'm a big
I've watched like every literally every
season of drag race even the first one
which is not super easy to do are you
watching all-stars right now I am
watching all starts right okay are you
rooting for anyone in particular I'm a
big Jujubee fan oh I like Jujubee and
also shake cool a is just yes that's who
I was trying to think of yeah yeah okay
and like Shay I'm doing on spoiling but
like this is coming out far in the
future
she was in the bottom of the of the most
recent episode that I watched and that
was very scary for me and Catherine Oh
same I was and because the rules of this
also are very like survivor style rules
very I don't like it no doubt your
biggest threat that it feels like oof
that there's a lot of psychological
warfare going on yeah I like drag races
always felt like it's a it's
intentionally avoided that survival
style like get rid a biggest threat in
part because like you don't want to have
a final between like two queens who
aren't great like you want the best
people to reach the end so that the like
last three people are amazing right and
and you like see it and believe it and
so you don't want you know yeah you
don't want to lose those those people
but I think that there's that culture
kind of has stood up and prot and
hopefully will will hold up but I do
really like the lip-sync assassin that's
very - that's a great innovation and I'm
super into it it's so fun and also
having watched the untucked where they
show you like the arrival of the
lip-sync assassin and knowing that it is
super secretive and none of the girls
know who it is Moo it makes me so
excited yeah yeah well that first that
first lip-sync with Eevee oddly I was
like well I mean I guess that was the
best one at the tone I was like I will
buckle up every single Friday night and
wait for this I can't it's so I know
that's why the Alyssa Edwards one was a
little disappointing but I heard
conspiracy theories that they've like
edited around her like doing super great
to try it yeah you can't you can't have
the award just keep piling up I think
yeah yeah totally because then there's
also all the question marks around like
how long does the lip sync assess and
have to prepare for this song versus
like the Queen's that are on set all day
I just want to I love it I love it yeah
I love that I love the drag race
community to like people just spend a
lot of time thinking and knowing and
learning and yeah it's good it's really
beautiful
okay we're gonna take one last break
when we get back we have some Internet
questions for you Hank green we'll be
right back with more not to eat
thank you okay Hank before we get into a
couple questions from the internet I'm
gonna ask you the two questions that
every single guest on the podcast is
asked to answer and the first since
you've been on before
I don't recall exactly what your answers
were to these questions so we'll see
someone can go back and check and see if
they're the same
the first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at Oh
Eddie I probably told the story of the
time that I threw cold spaghetti at a
friend of mine and gotten a lot of
trouble
I apologized to KC for that it'd be gosh
you know obviously I can't and I'm sure
I'm not the only one to say this I can't
throw cold spaghetti at Donald Trump
because like I don't want to go to
prison and like that's currently illegal
like very illegal well a lot of people
have just flat-out said they would so
yeah a lot of people in prison yeah well
the question is do I have amnesty
yeah hmm and this can change on a daily
basis this is just who in this moment
that we're recording this podcast alive
or dead would you most want to throw it
out yeah it's so hard to not throw cold
spaghetti at Donald Trump like it's just
hard
I mean imagine the tweet that would come
out of that situation who has that level
of self control to not do that so to
throw to someone like him it's just so
embarrassing yeah right yeah and he's
like always he like hates it whenever
like somebody seems like his makeup on
this collar and any like appearance of
being imperfect is so like counter to
his narcissism that I'm just like I just
want to dirty that boy up I think that'd
be great so is that your final answer
that's my final answer
all right wonderful
the next question as always tell us your
worst pants shooting story or a close
call but you can only use three words or
three small phrases or some kind of
combination so mine for example is
college jogging front lawn
right I think that my last one was my
waffle stomp yes oh yes that phrase I
learned from you and has never left my
brain since but okay I've got plenty
because I have ulcerative colitis
so I there's a number of times tonight
what about seat belt sign on wait what
was I should have prepped it better I
knew what story I was gonna tell I just
didn't know how I was gonna say it okay
you content you can edit you can take it
back what's the what's the area of the
okay I found the work it's three words
is not enough or a small phrase I could
to say like I could just say stuck on
the tarmac you can say that so wait what
is it stuck stuck stuck on the tarmac
which is four words but you know you
know when like your plane uh like it
starts to go but then it's like no
actually we're not gonna go yeah well
when it like lands and it's like well
the gates not open so we're just gonna
sit here yes there that that period of
time from when the the Pope like the
seatbelt light goes on to when you
arrive at the gate it can be a very long
time when you have an active ulcerative
colitis flare and uh and I actually like
she saw me and I was like sweating and
like you know in like obvious distress
and the students was like are you okay
and I was like I need to go very badly
to the bathroom and she was like I'll
tell the pilot and so like they stopped
the line so I can poo walk to the back
and they like yeah
and then like just they were like well
we're not gonna we'll stay here until
you get back to your seat because you
can't get up while they're on the ground
there's like very strict FAA rules right
oh no so we'll let you alleviate
yourself but we're all gonna know
waiting and why I got like pure green I
like like actual like significant pain
and yeah but you know you're not the
first person that they've had to do
something I guess that's how I remind
myself like it would have been way worse
for everybody if I'd shat on the plane
seat hugely massively terrible no I've
been stuck on the tarmac with a very
over full bladder and it's yeah I've
read it really opens up a new part of
your creative problem-solving brain that
you didn't know existed of like how can
I use this blanket as a temporary diaper
situation for myself possibly explain
with no one know it's and also like I
watch a lot of Survivor now and like
they put their bodies through insanity
that it's really truly like the mind
over matter situation of I'll think
myself into comfort right now I have a
superpower called my brain yeah I got a
couple of surprising tricks that
prevents me from pooping when I
otherwise would poop it's all about it's
all I understand one thing that I don't
know like you you do this to yourself
you have a whole section of your podcast
about poop so it's yeah it's like well
that's the thing is that I feel like
this could be your third book I think
people yeah it's not something that you
know is necessarily enjoyable
conversation it's cathartic conversation
because it everyone has had difficulties
in situations with it and so I like I
like commiserating rather than shaming
yeah I feel there's a weird thing where
I feel like if I try and like hold my
poop in with my butt muscle with my
actual sphincter it doesn't work it just
like tightens down and pushes on it and
if I can like there's like a muscle
inside that's like further up that I can
relax and it takes a lot of it's like a
meditative
thing and it's like I feel like like
something your brain like yeah I'm some
kind of like a special monk who can
control his like the speed of his
heartbeat except it's my poop I can make
it and make it sort of like come back up
a little bit I might never have to poop
ever again if I have mastered this I
love it okay here's a couple Internet
questions for you real quick before we
wrap everything up speaking of all of
these you know southern hemisphere
shenanigans someone's to know what would
April Mays pants shooting story be you
said you've created all of these stories
about all the characters that help you
you know flesh them out yeah emotionally
yeah I think I think April Mays fan
shooting story would definitely be like
a to drunk mid hookup
like sudden pause you know cheap sheets
[Laughter]
okay what's the weirdest and or most
embarrassing thing that Orin has said or
done very recently we were was we were
what we listened to this podcast called
my brother my brother and me as these
three brothers and they make very funny
jokes and and tell people bad advice and
they say [ __ ] a lot and we are now at
the age where we're gonna have to stop
listening to it because he looked down
at my phone and saw the podcast art or
this podcast and he thought about it for
a moment and then you said [ __ ] now
like that's what you think the podcast
is cause like you see that picture and
like your first thought is is just the
word [ __ ] that's so interesting I wonder
why that word it must be that I mean
it's a great word like it's very sticky
and like he can tell like even though we
tried our best to not make a big deal
out of when he says it or when we say
it's a superpower it so you can know
your animals know that you're stressed
out and you don't even realize yeah yeah
he's definitely he he he says [ __ ] all
the time and it's like a problem doesn't
know what it is he like walks around and
he like says words like he says words
all the time where he's sort of like
working out his like language center of
his brain and he'll be like headphone
yeah because you can't fault him all he
had were noises before he developed into
words but he's still just testing out
noises yeah oh that's great okay someone
to know if you could get paid in
anything other than money what would you
want
I mean tacos like really good tacos
though there's a place of Missoula
called Camino and they have these
amazing that they make their own
tortillas and it's just I like and if if
it well I guess I should broaden it and
say just stuff like meals from the
Camino and that includes margaritas
great yeah if you get paid in those it's
wonderful yeah a lot of people asked
what side of tick-tock is he on I'm on
the Pelican side of tick-tock what does
this mean so so that so tick-tock is
about like it's algorithmically based
and so it is constantly like showing you
little bits of stuff and then seeing
what you engage with and then it's sort
of like it's artificial intelligences
group you into groups and so there's
like the gay side of tick-tock and the
straight side of tick-tock and like okay
once you sort of like migrate over to
the gay side of tick-tock you see less
and less straight tick-tock but there's
also like these weird things that happen
where the the group gets hijacked by a
meme so for example there was very for a
while beans tick-tock it's still a thing
but like bean stick is kind of on its
way out a little bit of a feel to me
where there's just like it was very like
weird bean content was surfacing to the
the people who are like not you know
normal people kind of like through
Evon weirdness really strange but very
good being content okay
and and there's a lot of people who who
of course then place value on the
different parts and they sort of like if
you're on beam beam tick-tock then or
then you're like then you're on like
elite tick-tock not on like basic
tick-tock oh wow okay well I tried to
create my own like safe space on
tick-tock which is called pelic talk and
it's the Pelican side of tick-tock where
we took where we talk about pelicans and
it's just me I think I mean it has to
start a movement has to start somewhere
yeah and but as as long as you use the
same hashtags then like so occasionally
people will get like for Hank green
Pelican tick-tocks in a row and they're
like is Pelican our pelicans an animal
of choice for you
I do love pelicans Catherine used to
work at a wildlife rehab and so I've had
some like straight-up very like close
interactions with pelicans they've kind
of terrified me I think they're really
big yeah they're very much bigger than
you assume they are when you get close
to them and they're very pterodactyl
like yeah no absolutely they there are
Terra Don's that that not just look like
pelicans but we think like art like
convergently evolved just sort of the
same feeding strategies so are basically
giant pelicans but they're great they're
very weird they have there's a lot of
great things to know about pelicans and
there's also some good there's also some
misinformation about I like some some
science communication I'd like to do
around you know what how pelicans work
and don't work so I've got helican tic
TOCs all planned out actually Wow I was
gonna ask you someone want to know what
is your absolute favorite weird-looking
animal but I mean I don't know there's
another I don't know that pelicans are
it there is a kind of sea slug okay that
I'm I think that I'm more into and I
can't remember the name of it but
they're really pretty they're like these
blue sea slugs I'll look it up and
the thing that we were just talking
about Portuguese man aways it's called
the blue Lucas the bogus Glau yes okay
yeah to say and and I found out about
this because I'm doing I'm doing
research on Man O'War right now and the
blue Glaucus actually predates
Portuguese Man O'War which is very hard
to do because they're like floating
around on the top of the ocean and these
are sea slugs which you would think of
be on the bottom but they also inflate a
bladder inside of their body float up to
the top of the surface eat on the
Manowar and then you're thinking but
those are like super stinging animals
right they the blue cloud 'kiss absorbs
and takes the stinging cells of the Man
O'War and uses them on its own body to
then incapacitate other Man O'War so
like once it gets one Man O'War it
becomes more powerful because it can use
the stinging cells from its devoured
prey to attack its family whoa
and they're also very very pretty and
you look at them and like there's
there's a lot of pictures of people like
holding them in their hands but they're
like don't pick them up because they can
totally sting you yeah it sounds like it
so they basically take on the power from
their first prey and use it to kill
their other prey mm-hmm and those are
your favorite weird-looking animals well
they're also gorgeous but they are there
it does seem a little bad yeah probably
my favorite right now is the pelican
though in terms of like actual affinity
I feel like like my Patronus is a
pelican actually says like like
resonates a lot more than other
patronesses I've had enough yeah that
makes sense
I think we've reached the end of the
podcast but before you go usually as a
gift to our guest for making time we
offer them a personalized fortune cookie
but because we are doing this virtually
we have a virtual personalized fortune
cookie for you that I believe melissa
has emailed to you I see it okay and you
can open it and read it aloud okay it
says knock knock who's there
April just kidding we won't actually
know if it's her or an imposter being
her until we read the sequel which
technically isn't out yet and I guess
that's kind of your fault no just
kidding we're sorry we just are really
excited for the new book thank you never
had such an information dense portion
before Hank where can people find you
and listen to you and read the new book
or pre-order it or get it everything if
they don't already know okay I'm on
tick-tock my name is Hank green but I am
and I am hank green one because I
couldn't get Hank green I was too late
Hank I'm Hank green everywhere else but
on YouTube on vlogbrothers with my
brother John and I also make science
content on scishow my podcast third year
Hank and John which is an advice podcast
that is bad with my brother and why did
this which is which is my wife
criticizing my Twitter feed and my new
book of beautifully foolish endeavor is
out July 7th which is either already
happened or will happen very soon
wonderful go get that book I'm so
excited to have people read it oh it's
gonna be so great is it available on
audio book as well yeah actually the
audio book is we worked really hard on
it and there's podcasts and in the book
like excerpts from podcasts and we like
recorded them as podcasts that's so cool
that's awesome
well everyone go check out all of it
most importantly the book and you know
follow the tick tocks
see where the beans are going Thank You
Hank
thank you guys we'll see you guys next
time when the episode of not too deep
goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep not too
deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa D months
edited by Shireen Lonnie Eunice
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]